welcome back to CBS this morning I'm
Gail came with Anthony Mason and Tony -
Coco calls for prison reform are rising
after a spike in violence in
correctional facilities in Mississippi
over the last 10 days a total of five
inmates were killed in different state
prisons at a troubled site called
Parchman farm two violent inmates
managed to escape from there last week
well they have since been caught mark
Strassmann is outside of that facility
but mark this is really part of a
national issue right
it is Gayle very much so a national
issue America has the world's highest
incarceration rate but staffing at
federal prisons that shrunk in recent
years and critics consider Mississippi's
prison system to be among America's most
troubled underfunded understaffed and
violent inmates here at the parchment
facility say it's not the guards who run
the place it's the gangs inmates using
contraband cell phones allegedly shot
these images although CBS News hasn't
confirmed that independently this is
Parchman farm home to Mississippi's
death row and lately a killing field for
warring prison gangs three inmates were
murdered here in three days
ma-mutt brother stay out beat up gets in
a cell with the rivalry how could you do
it at least one lawsuit alleges barbaric
prison conditions rats open sewage
abusive guards corruption yet since 2014
Mississippi has slashed funding and
staffing gangs like the Vice Lords and
black gangster disciples have thrived
inside Mississippi Governor phil Bryant
we are going to stop it we have it under
control as best we can but Mississippi's
prison staffing is in crisis almost half
the roughly 1300 Corrections positions
in three major facilities remain
unfilled salary is one issue even with a
degree guards start around $26,000
roughly the national poverty level for a
family of four sixty-five percent of the
state's corrections officers are women
why are 65 percent of the guards women
because men don't want the jobs
Jerry Mitchell is the Dean of
Mississippi's investigate
of reporters he has looked into its
prison problems for years are the
inmates the gangs really in charge
inside they are in charge of where you
sleep where you eat how much you get to
eat you have towers that are empty you
know that you used to have guards that
don't have guards now and what do you do
state officials admit the gangs are a
problem but they deny that the gangs are
out of control
mississippi state troopers have been
working here in parchment in recent days
some of them told us the regular
corrections officers stopped coming to
work because it was too dangerous inside
Elleni no that's that's quite a picture
mark and we understand that the prison
also has corruption problems corruption
among guards Anthony has been a problem
here for years maybe not surprising
given how little these folks are paid in
return the inmates get drugs cigarettes
and cell phones the cell phones that
took the images and that story we just
put on and but without those cell phones
in those images we might not have a such
a clear picture of what's happening
inside you know and it's not a pretty
picture mark thank you very much
you